voilà c'est en petite scène de nicolas
bedos et au théâtre hébertot avec guy
bedos et gabriel valence il y avait pas
mal hein c'est vraiment toi les gens se
marrent quoi c'est vraiment un truc qui
va marcher ça va être dit il ya un bruit
qui court dans paris j'ai pas entendu la
piège du bigard une demi-heure téléphone
qui pleurait bidiar expliquer à quel
point ton fils écrivait bien parce que
ton talent on connaît mais il paraît que
au delà c'est pas du népotisme il avait
appris son gamin parce que c'était son
fils il paraît qu'ils arrivent des
fautes il ya un moteur extraordinaire
et moi je vais dépêchés de venir vous
voir il paraît qu'il est bienvenu savoir
paris paraît qui s'est enrayé très bon
la critique est pas mauvaise on a parlé
d' annuler dans dans le figaro le figaro
d'une très jolie soirée tendre et drôle
en parlant de l'auteur nicolas bedos il
est doué ce jeune auteur en parlant de
vous une comédienne délicate
très juste qui refusent les facilités
émotionnel surtout ils ont rien et
j'apprends tout lu mais je ronronne
j'adore ça dans le succès j'adore ça et
puis surtout ce rôle
c'est le plus gros que je vais mourir
mais c'est un rôle qui convient à
maturité je l'exagèrent un peu en et
sans pousser en ayant laissé pousser la
barbe
parce que ma préférence à mai
bien brille elle fait du théâtre depuis
l'âge de 12 13 ans dans c à vous a pris
ben ça m'a pris j'ai sauté dans un cours
de théâtre
une fois et puis j'ai adoré ça et j'ai
su tout de suite que c'est ce que je
voulais faire j'avais fait de la mule
beaucoup de musique à vent mais sans
vraiment savoir si c'était ça ou pas et
puis voilà le terme
vous avez beaucoup d'assurance pour
quelqu'un qui va me comme ils en ont je
crois que j'ai tout pour être sécurisé
et puis et c'est un bonheur tous les
soirs moi je suis en plus c'est bien
parce que tous les sens on ne se lasse
pas moi je me lasse pas d'entendre ce
que fergie je me lasse pas de relire le
texte enfin c'est extrêmement riche
c'est drôle c'est cetc fallu que demande
le peuple tout va bien et les gens ross
le reçoivent avec beaucoup
d'intelligence et ça fait plaisir
alors il y en a un autre qui étonne avec
son âge c'est donc nicolas qui a quoi 24
ans non tu dois être très très fier à ce
que le talent est pas forcément
transmissibles je veux pas non plus
l'armée sortir des violences d'alou sur
le père le fils vise le plein on sait
pas encore c'est un auteur geci sa pièce
avait été mauvais je ne leur ai pas joué
ouais il ay là il a quand même une
maturité incroyable qu'est ce qu'il a il
a vieilli prématurément ou quoi mais je
me sens plus jeune que lui parfois
franchement gdd candeur
qui sans ridicule à côté il a une
maturité de quinquagénaires je trouve
mais la grande île et guy bedos au c1
mais moi j'ai dit guy bedos il ya un
sperme artistique très fertile parce que
leslie bedos moi j'ai lu son livre je
suis gaucher aller à écrire lydman vague
haussière
l'agresseur et je la connais un petit
peu et je trouve qu'elle aussi elle est
pas dénuée mais non tu me permets que je
rends hommage à j je connais pas ça
parce que ça normal je me mets pas de
toute la famille non j'ai deux autres
filles qui viennent bien c'est vrai
qu'il voulait quitter l'école déjà l'âge
de 8 ans ton fils
oui j'étais obligé dirait nicolas jean
dunand et chose qu'ont dû obliger déjà
compris l'enlever de l'école c'est
interdit par la loi il va y avoir les
jambes bas il voulait quitter l'école à
8 en 8 barbet a alors b et un jour ma
femme est rentré en me disant alors le
mot a été prononcé
ton fils est un surdoué well as
peut-être qu'il va s'en sortir je sais
pas on va trouver un moyen de sylla il
avait une maladie grave
à 19 ans il était quasiment cadres
supérieurs et canal+ avant que ça ne
devienne canal mois
et alors à la sorbonne il est resté une
demi heure quoi il derrière le plafond
est meilleur il était en avance il s'est
mis à écrire un film parce que tu as été
beaucoup plus tenté par le cinéma au
départ c'est un garçon qui a été menée
dans les salles obscures
et voilà et que dire de plus non